hours before the
actor alec baldwin fatally shot a
cinematographer on the new mexico set of
rust with a prop gun a half dozen camera
crew workers walked off the set to
protest working conditions the camera
operators and their assistants were
frustrated by the conditions surrounding
the low budget film including complaints
about long hours long computes and
collecting their paychecks according to
three people familiar with the matter
who are not authorized to comment
we're also learning i believe we have
this story is from people the gun alec
baldwin fired on rust sat contained a
live round prop masters union says now
this is normally i don't care too much
about the pop culture stuff it's not
policy i'm but this is alec baldwin an
overtly political actor a violent and
angry individual on online who has been
a very prominent activist whether you
like it or not or you think it's silly
he has been
he is
you know look many of these people i
don't want to say him directly but i'd
assume him along with many others are
anti-gun and that's how it manifests
they want to play with weapons on set
and they don't take responsibility for
it so this is a gun issue it's a
political issue and now i'm seeing all
of these people tweet at me it's not
alex baldwin's fault no no i said it
it's more than 100 his fault because not
only at the time when i said that if the
gun is given to you it is in your hand
you are responsible for what comes out
of it period that doesn't mean he's a
murderer it just means he's responsible
it could be negligence it could be
manslaughter or it could be accidental
but it's on him the other issue is now
that we're learning that the crew had
been describing gun safety issues
already
if he was not aware of that when he was
handling a weapon his fault yeah so
here's my one question as an ignorant
canadian i took a firearm safety course
but i when i saw the term misfire i just
asked the question is it not firing when
it's supposed to or is it uh firing by
accident i look this up a misfire means
that it doesn't fire at all then there's
a thing called a hang fire where it
doesn't fire for about 30 seconds and
then it fires okay that's interesting i
don't know about if it just goes off
without even touching it if that's also
considered a misfire i couldn't figure
that out well another thing we have to
add to this discussion is that if
someone knows gun safety if someone
knows how to use guns some if someone is
properly trained on how to use guns they
could prevent a lot of these incidences
from happening because you know hey i
got a real gun i got real bullets and
you know the difference between fake
bullets dummy bullets fake guns prop
guns and rail guns so this is uh this is
a huge tragedy we're hearing other
reports that uh alex said why was i
given a live gun after this incident so
again i have to kind of say he's hot
didn't he say yeah yeah i believe
something along those lines the reports
are still coming in the police say that
they're still investigating all of this
but it is very prominent that a lot of
the people who are the most anti-gun
don't know anything about guns and
that's that's something that should be
stopped immediately and people should
take some time and and learn about them
because uh i mean these instances could
be prevented with just information and
knowledge but sadly a lot of the times
we can't even talk about these issues so
i tweeted that this is alec baldwin's
fault i didn't say he should go to
prison i didn't say you know in in one
tweet i have expressed that you know he
should be charged um to a certain degree
there should be an investigation i'll
put it that way but i get all these
these lefties these these you know
because they love alec baldwin because
he is in their tribe they're like it's
the prop master's fault and i'm like
prop master wasn't holding a gun it's
it's crazy to me people then said so tim
actually believes in more gun control
now and i'm like yo i'm pretty sure it
is the two-way advocates who are the
ones demanding responsibility for gun
owners not the government imposing
restrictions on the people
so well we'll just contrast it to the
cow rittenhouse case i mean cal
rittenhouse actually knew how to use a
gun only used it in self-defense
purposes and they were eager for him to
be prosecuted with every imaginable
crime even crimes that didn't apply to
him under the constitutional
circumstances and yet here you have a
celebrity a high-profile personality
overtly political over the last decade
uh who chose to be very anti-gun who
killed somebody because he didn't have
basic training and and that's it that's
right how do i mean i don't even
understand how they have a live gun on a
set i appreciate it's a prop and that to
me means there should never be anything
near bullets in it so is it is it
shooting a shell of a of a
blank bullets bullets are banned from
these kinds of movies so how did this
happen i mean there's a lot of
accusations about how the workers were
treated here there's a lot of uh
accusations about scabs
crazy there's a lot of you know a lot of
implications with people just being
brought in out of nowhere so i mean this
happened before it's not like this never
happened before this happened to brandon
lee bruce lee's son was shot and killed
because of another accident where
someone had a live bullet on uh you know
the production facility so they made
sure to ban all live bullets from
production facilities and and this
happened again i don't think it's an
accident
i'm not saying it was an intentional
murder or anything like that but you
know when i'm thinking about this story
i got my biases all right and i'll tell
you one of them we've got some replica
guns here we've got uh we've got airsoft
we have actual mock replicas for like
basic training purposes it's like a
piece of metal that just slides back
doesn't really do much
and you know i was just explaining to to
the viva barnes before we started the
show like i'll also ask someone like hey
you know the gun safety rules right
never point anybody finger off the
trigger the gun is always loaded and
i'll hand them the weapon and the first
thing they always do is just like oh wow
and i'm like your fingers on the trigger
and you're pointing it at people you see
you failed the test when you do that
when i so they say oh but alec baldwin's
got training and he's safe my assumption
is that he was goofing around he did not
respect that weapon he clearly did not
check it if they're saying it was a live
bullet that means he didn't open it up
and say
you got to be handed the okay if it's if
you're getting a revolver the revolver
should be open pointed down handed to
you by the by the armor of the set the
prop master who says this is a colt 45
loaded with 45 you know 45 long call
revolver we are closing the revolver now
when you pull the trigger it will fire a
live round he's handed a gun he doesn't
look at he doesn't open he doesn't check
and then it misfires whatever whatever
whatever that means i'll play devil's
advocate because i really don't like
alec baldwin but um
setting aside the politics is overt you
know hateful rhetoric irrelevant for the
time being if i'm alec baldwin and i'm a
hollywood actor and someone says this is
a prop for a scene here you go take it
look
i don't even know how
to know that it's a real it's easy with
a little bit of control hold on hold on
let's let's make it let's make a legal
argument of it a legal argument out of
it
i hand ian a loaded gun
and i say don't worry ian it's not
loaded you can shoot viva and then he
does
will ian get in trouble if well
at that point a loaded gun or sorry a
real gun i would say yes but i said i
probably don't know but if you say it's
a prop i don't even have a reason to
know that it's a real gun i would say
you're the one who's going to be guilty
of setting up something cataclysmic
because if i have no reason to believe
it's a real gun do you think a court
would would tell like if i say this is a
prop gun don't worry go ahead and point
it at him and pull the trigger the
court's going to be like no no it's not
ian's fault he was just pointing a gun
and pulling the trigger the problem is
someone gave him bad info if alec
baldwin was a 20 year old actor never
done anything before that might work but
the problem is he's been around for too
long so he doesn't know exactly what a
prop gun is i mean if i was looking at
prosecuting him i would be looking at
that experience and that would be the
problem it's not just
sorry sorry
there was a comment from someone i think
one of the one of the uh someone who's
worked with baldwin who said they worked
with him before they knew he was well
trained and very safe that's actually a
really good point you could argue
there's no way he wouldn't have known
yeah there's also a difference between
blanks and real bullets you could tell
the difference just by looking at them
you know blanks obviously don't have
that top part and that that projectile
that goes and and
yeah the bullet
so so obviously the two are very
different and if someone you know just
checked someone just looked at it and
especially if he's just picking up a
firearm
i mean i wish you would have checked but
here's the other thing my understanding
is they never actually point the guns at
people anyway that's the other bottom
line even with my kid we tell them not
to point the nerf dart gun at people
because you just don't do it out of
habit this i'm i'm only giving him the
benefit of the doubt that if he has no
reason to believe it's a real gun
holding live rounds and i don't even
know why that would be on a set how it
gets there in the first place and you
may have cumulative responsibility here
one aspect of negligence coupled with
another how did it get there everybody
sued for
myself i'm kind of wondering about a
criminal element here
sabotage is a interesting
creative thought
i don't even think about that you've got
a crew that's walking off protesting
saying the conditions are bad you've
also probably got low budget people who
aren't being you know properly vetted
someone put a live ball in that gun yeah
i mean why workers were sending out
messages on social media saying things
like quote i am literally on the show in
new mexico with him and the producers on
that movie are are treating the local
crew like effing dog
crap i'm not gonna family friendly show
so i can't say that but that's exactly
what one of the workers uh a part of
this crew said and he goes on and he
details a lot about a lot of bad
conditions i'm doing a little bit of
speculation here too but we were we were
uh asking you know everybody's been
asking like what kind of gun was it what
kind of round was it here's here's my my
best guess because we don't have all the
full details we got this from imdb a 13
year old boy left to fend for himself
and his younger brother following the
death of their parents in 1880s kansas
all right
well what kind of gun would they be
using in a movie about the 1880s i'd
imagine it's going to be a revolver
i'm not an expert on this stuff but i'd
imagine that he was armed with a 45 long
coal and so i guess what happened was
the single bullet went uh hit the woman
and then it went through her and then
hit
the director as well and he he didn't
have life-threatening injuries he went
to the hospital some people were
speculating that it was a blank and it
shattered the camera sending shrapnel
into her or something like that but now
we have we have the article from the
people apparently union was saying it
was a live round and a live round that
went through one person and then hit a
second person and went to the hospital
and so luke mentioned this look was like
it must have been a 45 and i was like
45. it went through one person i know so
i mean
there needs to be a lot of power and i'm
asking myself why would the gun be
pointed at the cinematographer in any
case when i first heard the story i
thought maybe it was the stunt person
involved but why would the gun have been
pointing been pointed at a
cinematographer i'm thinking he was
shooting towards camera she was right on
the camera and he was shooting like
right past it and the director was
behind her on the monitor watching so
they were both there in the line and he
was just like you don't even pay
attention to the crew when you're acting
it's like they're not there pretty much
and so that was probably going through
his mind actually i i think that's a
good possibility uh you know ian's point
uh often when people are learning how to
shoot when they grip the gun incorrectly
they could squeeze their hand causing
the handgun to move in other directions
so what i've been told when i've gone to
these classes is that people will
typically pull down when they pull the
trigger their hand makes the barrel
point down yeah but some people will
pull left so if alec baldwin has the gun
and he squeezes his hand not knowing how
to use the weapon and it causes the
barrel to shift to the left and she's to
his left he hits her one thing that's
concerning is they called a misfire a
misfire by definition means that it
never went off so it wasn't a misfire it
was maybe a hanging fire or maybe it
just got fired accidentally which i
don't think is considered a misfire i
still have diff great difficulty
understanding why there's a live bullet
that's why it sounds criminal it it it
there's an interesting aspect given the
tweets set on you know the ambiance on
the set the environment on the set it
sounds like there might have been
something else like potential sabotage
wow but i would before blaming alec
baldwin in as much as i loathe him as a
politician political character i i would
i would say there should never be
bullets on a set and right it'll be
everybody that rule already exists yeah
so i don't know if it wasn't followed
then then who there's going to be some
production companies
why didn't he know i mean that's the
problem right he's done this a lot how
did he not know there was so do you
think criminal
i mean
he should be under criminal
investigation without that people are
saying manslaughter well
uh civil easily uh against everybody
against everybody yeah but criminally
you'd have to investigate and you'd want
to investigate everything connected to
her whether there could be a backstory
they're beyond the union backs i mean
you know look i don't want to jump the
shark on our speculation but having an
affair
you would definitely look at that right
and you'd have to look at that right
there's a very interesting video of a
crew with will smith looking at replica
and fake alleged firearms
and you see one of the crew members pick
it up and point it directly at will
smith will smith smacks it out of his
hands grabs it
takes out the magazine i saw this going
around on instagram um
takes out the firearm puts it in the
safe direction takes out the magazine
and of course checks it to make sure
that there's nothing in there and then
hands it back to the crew member being
like these people aren't uh following
basic gun safety rules here but but he
was taking it seriously on a movie set
because you know a lot of these prop
guns are usually just real guns with
blank bullets check it out we got it
this is uh this was bad boys
yeah so
yeah so you
you can see it never is going to happen
now that guy points it right into his
face
boom smacks it down grabs it out
checks the clip well this is this
he does it right thank you will
and then and then he goes like the ends
yeah that looks like it might have been
a setup promo for the movie that's
pretty i mean that could have been
that's great um what was the other thing
i was going to say i forgot now it will
come back but i mean he's he's done it
too long not to have known something was
wrong so he had to be out of it yeah oh
this is what i was going to say that
it's for everybody out there they should
know also that having blanks in there
doesn't necessarily make it 100 safe
either from the uh brandon lee story no
no that's the i think hexam which is the
one that had the leftover shell from the
black no no no no the black so blanks
kill you uh a blank will kill you people
so i've got a revolver i've got the
governor smith and western governor and
you know i went to a range i brought
some weapons asked the guys like give me
give me give me a low down tell me what
for and one of the things i said is
don't put your hands don't hold the
revolver with your hands where the the
uh the cylinder is because the gases and
the explosion come out sideways so you
gotta you'll hurt yourself
that's just the concussive force of the
round a blank itself has enough power to
kill you at close range so that that
story i guess was like in 1984 a guy on
the set of a tv show had a blank a gun
with a blank in it and he just
took himself out the brandon lee thing
they had dummy rounds which are
improvised from live cartridges they
have the powder removed but in that his
case they didn't remove the powder okay
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you